the mass mandate comes down to an end
some businesses aren't taking them off
just yet mary jane belliesa has more
from one local grocery store and
customers who say it comes down to
keeping each other safe
i'm here at the smiths on decatur and
desert inn where shoppers and employees
are still wearing their masks i was also
at an albertson's earlier in the day on
charleston and rainbow masked there too
some people didn't know the mandate was
lifted until i told them as governor
steve sisilak drops the mask mandate a
las vegas grocery store is keeping the
mass policy in place nikata market of
japan's store manager tamanari sagami is
not ready to have the employees or
customers take them off for us it won't
change we will keep the mask on and then
i will ask the customer keep asking
customers to wear the mask for the
safety
yeah inside of us won't change shopper
joe badager says this move is a sign of
normalcy
i'm not opposed to continue to wear it
it's a simple price to pay to prevent
the spread of germs so
until it's all gone i'll probably wear
it while doug ramer is excited about the
end of the mandate he says it should be
optional so it's great we finally get
our individual liberties back it's up to
the responsibility of each individual
person i mean if you want to wear a mask
wear a mask debra williams is a store
field representative for many grocery
stores in the valley she says she'll
continue to keep her mask on as a
precaution i have family members who are
in the medical field
and because of that
until they
give me the okay
i will continue to wear my mask enrique
malthavon agrees i am going to still
wear mine
in public
however i respect everybody's rights if
they don't want to wear it it's on them
now as a reminder while the governor
lifted the mandate employers and
businesses can set their own policies so
don't be surprised if you see signs
posted outside the doors reporting here
at decatur and desert in mary jane
bolieza live local now